how do you go from this to the stuff of
pure nightmare fuel
we're about to find out ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the 10 million
dollar studio i'm your host coffee zilla
and today we got a new show for you a
new series
we're calling it gofundme garbage and
did i
completely yoink that yoink from uh
idubbbz kickstarter crap
yes basically i did great series great
concept
and i'm gonna so i hope you enjoy it
we're gonna
try to give it a fresh twist and we got
three products for you today
that didn't quite live up to the hype
listen we live in a time where showing
an idea is more important than actually
having proof of concept everything's so
futuristic now you gotta reinvent the
wheel on everything you gotta claim that
oh
i've rediscovered bikes we're gonna talk
about one of those today but we're gonna
eventually
walk our way to the pure nightmare fuel
that i teased you with the beginning
there but not before we talk
about our first uh little fail now i'd
like to give a shout out
to r slash kickstarters because they're
the ones who kind of
brought me onto this stuff you guys know
the reddit sleuths are on the job
little honorary internet detectives if i
do say so myself
and they caught these guys it's called
the three
one phase e-bike uh quick thing 397
thousand dollars rate now how do you
buy stuff before it's shown to be real
like right like or
how do you know it's really designed by
them i don't know people just back stuff
there's too much money out there yeah hi
um my name's james steward i'm the
founder and designer at three phase
the awareness now that there's a real
pressure on the environment
this is key now let me just say the
biggest key to a good uh
gofundme indiegogo kickstarter is all
about
the presentation the video even if it's
pure lies it could be complete lies and
we'll find out in this video what
this guy did lie about but uh it doesn't
matter as long as it makes you
feel something it's instantly funded
okay well let's go
people want to make a change and i
wanted to give people a tool
this really is what led us to design the
three-phase one
you hear that guys he designed the three
three phase in one okay great
it's designed in such a way that you can
step on and step off really easily
whoa careful there tiger
step on and step off really easily
revolutionary bike design guys you can
cycle it as a normal bike
so it's an e-bike or it's a normal bike
it's got the function for it all
four hundred thousand dollars now what
did people find out well
they started to post updates you know
once you actually fund the product then
you have to actually build
the product production has begun they
say we didn't want to miss the new
year's uh celebration
or to slow us down so we fired up the
assembly lines and they show this little
assembly line wow that's cute but
someone noticed it looks like a
different production line of an
alibaba store okay alibaba.com
that's the exact same picture that these
guys used for their indiegogo
revolutionary bike design guys they're
reinventing bikes
can you believe the audacity of this
raising oh now
four hundred thousand dollars it rate
went up since we talked about it
and you're not doing anything you've
just taken production stuff from other
people you're just buying it off alibaba
how insane is this you take an exit
this is like a new arbitrage instead of
actually drop shipping you just pretend
you invent something that's really
invented it's already exists
alibaba and then you sell it with some
high production you get an english voice
actor on there to tell you about
uh the the special design specs this
breaks
disc brakes what a clown you are a clown
oh man i can't believe this so that's go
fund me garbage
number one number two is uh quite
interesting given the recent state of
the virus with uh paramedic approved
first aid kits
right everyone's worried listen we just
had the snow the cold snap
in texas want to be a prepper so these
guys come out with this incredible
new product it's a med kit
basically knowing your protocols inside
and out or
staying up to date on training the true
secret is kindness
okay but but not though right i mean
you go to a hospital they go you're like
what are you gonna do to me doc
our true secret kindness my name's matt
and i've been working as a california
paramedic and first responder for nearly
10 years and during that time
good credibility right i have seen an
unimaginable amount of suffering
very sad much of which you can never
train for to the point but one of the
most discouraging things that i've
realized is just how few people are
prepared to handle a crisis 200 000
someone who is deeply passionate about
public health and personal safety
the fact that nearly half the people
listening to me right now do not own a
first
aid kit let alone have any first aid or
cpr training
this is truly unacceptable to me so i
decided to do something about it
the paramedic approved first aid kits
were built with three main factors in
okay so he's gonna talk to you about how
you know thanks to his traumatic
experiences
he built a first aid kit right what an
incredible story
except whoops what's this survival
workplace first
aid kit well oh gosh that looks a lot of
like the paramedic approved kit
which shouldn't exist right this
shouldn't exist because this guy this
paramedic designed it
with victims in mind right what a
scumbag huh
it's the same thing it's the existing
product just repackaged
unbelievable 200 000 i have to say
bold move let's see how it pays off for
him has anyone ever
been accused of fraud for this i mean is
there any such thing as like
kickstarter fraud i would be interested
to know that i don't know the laws
around this stuff i just think it's kind
of silly what's going on here
i had no idea this was a problem on
these gofundme things
until i started checking it out finally
last but
very not least we have uh uno brush
and this one is coming in on top with
a drum roll police total money raised
of 1.6 million dollars
wow this must be a hot new product
introducing the new way of brushing your
teeth something that hasn't changed
in 500 years yeah because we got it
right the first time
there's some things that we got right i
hate all these like entrepreneurs who
are like
do we need to redesign the mug hey leave
it
well maybe i'm being too judgmental
maybe i'm big too harsh let's watch
power and 360 degree wrap sonic
technology
the new unibrush is two times more
effective than regular toothbrushes
and how can they say that do they have
this does this thing already exist it
must already exist right for them to say
that
cleans 99.9 of your teeth surface plus
it brushes all of your teeth at once in
only six seconds
okay stop first of all that's six sec
seconds of unimaginable shame that
nobody's gonna be willing to go through
you couldn't pay me 1.6 million dollars
to put that in my mouth wow it's easy to
store clean and charge with the
minimalist danish designed
uv light docking station that eliminates
significant cleanliness flaws with
today's toothbrush
you know what americans love like
foreign things if it's just from another
country we're like
is that exotic the unibrush has earned
numerous awards worldwide including the
most innovative product by microsoft the
government is the world's first
anti-cavity toothbrush that combines an
ergonomic mouthpiece
patent-pending 360-degree wrapping
uniform and pulsing sonic vibration
listen i may be wrong here look it could
be a legit product i might have jumped
the shark on this one
if it's got an award by microsoft listen
bill gates has never been known to ju
like you know get behind any sketchy
product so you know what i'm totally
wrong
that deliver a refreshing clean to your
mouth teeth and gums
unlike anything you've ever experienced
we have a mission here's the founder
pitch
this always happens they have you know
the speaker but then you get introduced
to the founders now let me say
this guy the way he's standing is
aggressive he looks like he's ready to
either
take your money or sell you shoes i
don't know which
you want to make good old hygiene easy
and accessible for everyone hey
move dude look this guy's like is he
going to move
and we want you to help us this is
unibrush a solution that cleans all the
teeth simultaneously using
our specially developed i don't look
they're getting
models to do this and it's still this is
like when google glass came out
and they're like if we put tom cruise in
a dorky piece of eyewear are you guys
gonna think it's cool it's like no so i
think the most important part of this in
the part that probably everyone jumped
on
is the new design people got really
excited to look like they're gagged by
some futuristic alien species
so that's why it seems like everyone
back to write this patent-pending
formula
we pay our uniform with sonic vibrations
and fluid wave technology that work
together to flow toothpaste between each
and every tooth and below the gum line
getting into places a manual toothbrush
can't reach
okay so this is what these two stooges
did right these two
uh lovable young guys they look young so
anyway
hugely successful thing and they had a
concept
careful whenever anyone has just has a
concept because you may not get
what you thought you were gonna get and
true to four this is exactly what
happened
the first problem was when the uh blog
updated that they've been busy for the
last couple weeks working on a few
smaller appearance design changes uh oh
i thought you already had it a little
danish design wasn't good enough
next update of note was the update 13.
this is when everything went south you
went from like a minimalist
you know alien gag to a
death torture device that they would use
in guantanamo bay
what the hell is this this looks like
how you give somebody whiplash simulated
in a car
it looks like how you test the bite
strength of a snapping turtle what
is that this is not what they've
diverted from danish design i just got
to say that right now this does not look
like something
a danish designer would do there's
nothing about this that is appealing
that would have ever flown on
kickstarter or indiegogo or any of these
websites and this is what people are
getting at the end of the day
people are saying look in the comments i
was reading the comments they're brutal
they're like we don't even want this
anymore can i
take away my money and they're like well
we'll give you two
the point is to tell you guys hey don't
ever trust somebody with a prototype or
a concept there's a lot of dreamers in
this world
who think they're gonna be able to
redesign things before they realize that
actually
they're that way for a reason i have no
problem with industry disruption but i
mean
if you're gonna promise to reinvent the
toothbrush and then the way you reinvent
the toothbrush is like a thousand little
toothbrushes in your mouth that just
shake violently
that ain't so great but okay the danish
wouldn't have done it that's all i gotta
say
i hope you enjoyed this new series what
you think gofundme garbage is it a thing
do we like it
let me know in the comments below thanks
for watching and i will see you guys
up smell the tomorrow
[Music]